originalism is dead and neil Gorsuch
killed it
originalism they say you know we've
heard this word so many times in recent
years the judicial philosophy of Antonin
Scalia so important when the great
Scalia died that we replace him with an
originalist judge and we've got an
originalist judge and that judge was
Neal Gorsuch and Neal Gorsuch just
stabbed us in the back and Antonin
Scalia is rolling over in his grave we
got a terrible decision yesterday out of
the Supreme Court and it was all Gorsuch
his fault
this was a 6-3 decision so was the the
three conservatives it was amazing
because you would expect from everything
we'd heard in the media that Brett
Kavanaugh Trump's second pick would
maybe be the squishy guy but he wasn't
he was with the Conservatives he was
with Clarence Thomas he was with Sam
Alito then you had Neil Gore said she
was supposed to be more conservative he
sides with the squish John Roberts and
with the Liberals to deliver a terrible
decision on transgenderism this was
legislating from the bench
it was redefining sex to give credence
to this whole crazy gender ideology now
as part of the Civil Rights Act it's
hard to remember a worse decision than
this worst of all
worst of all here because this is going
to have wide effect beyond the Civil
Rights Act Beyond transgenderism this is
going to have effect on our whole
judicial process and theory Gorsuch
defended his stupid opinion with the
judicial philosophy of Antonin Scalia so
the broadly speaking what what this
judicial philosophy says is that we
should interpret the words in laws to
mean what they meant when they were
written and this is very difficult for
the decision that we got yesterday
because the whole gender theory that
goes into this decision didn't even
exist when the law was written so
there's no way to make that argument
this was a really really major setback
for President Trump this was a major
setback for the Constitution this was a
major setback for conservatives and it
was a warning because we have relied on
the judges right we have relied on the
courts and the message we got you
today from Gorsuch is the courts ain't
going to save us I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
we will get into this case we will get
into Sam Alito's excellent dissent and
we'll get into why this matters why does
some random case about transgender
employment that theoretically is going
to affect like 12 people in the country
what does that mean for us
it means a lot this is going to change
our judicial culture or legal culture or
interpretation of the Constitution it's
gonna affect every business in the
country it's gonna affect sports oh man
it's so bad have I mentioned that this
is bad
first though I I do want to get to the
question I asked yesterday in the
comments section I asked which cartoon
is gonna get cancelled next because you
know Sponge Bob Squarepants now to
survive has become gay and Elmer Fudd
has lost his gun and paw patrol is gone
because that involves the cops I asked
which one was gonna be canceled my
favorite answer from blue-collar
perspective is Bugs Bunny won't be
banned he was a crossdresser who fought
that white supremacist Elmer Fudd that's
a very good point you you make a good
point my question for you today if you
wouldn't mind letting me know how long
do you think Chaz will last Chaz is the
autonomous anarchist zone in Seattle and
it's going on now for like over a week
here maybe two weeks or something so
anyway I just want to know how long that
will last will it be stomped out within
the next few days or will it become the
next country like are we are we living
in the 1776 of Chad do let me know also
before we get to this very important
case I got to thank our friends over at
Rock Auto Rock auto man you know how
much I love these guys because I don't
know anything about Auto Parts so I go
to the auto parts store the
brick-and-mortar they never have the
part I need then they go online they
probably go to rockauto.com they order
the part that I need them they charge me
double I don't like that very much
rockauto.com is so much easier than
doing all of that you know you don't
need to get these crazy answers like hey
is your Odyssey an L X or an X I don't
know my Odyssey is then you know they
they usually order the part online so
rockauto.com is a family business it's
been in business for twenty years which
is pretty much the whole history of
online their catalog super easy to
navigate even for me I don't
anything about cars you always get the
best prices on rockauto.com they're
reliably low and they're the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers so
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts it doesn't make any
sense I really trust these guys go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
Knowles Canada wles and there how did
you hear about us box so that they know
we sent you the case before the Supreme
there were a number of cases the big one
is Bostock the Clayton County Georgia
that's how you're gonna hear this
decision referred to in Bostock the the
case revolves around this County Clayton
County firing Gerald Bostick for be cut
for conduct unbecoming a county employee
after he began to participate in a gay
recreational softball league so the
question is can you discriminate against
people on the basis of their sexual
behaviors or if they're a man wearing a
dress or something like that now you
might say I don't want to discriminate
against gay people yeah okay I mean I
don't think anybody wants to
discriminate against anybody but the
question is is this is there a law about
this now Congress in recent years has
tried to pass laws to broaden the Civil
Rights Act to protect people on the
basis of their sexual preferences or on
the basis of their sexual identity
meaning transgenderism those those
attempts have failed okay so the
Congress has acknowledged that there is
no current protection for that in the
law that's why they've tried to pass new
laws and they've failed because people
don't want to protect that it obviously
leads to a lot of difficult questions
are we now saying that a church can't
can't fire people based on certain
behaviors that maybe contradict their
moral codes well currently there are
some religious protections we'll see how
long that lasts but what about religious
business owners you know people who
practice their faith their faith is
integral to their business but they're
not a formed Church now they're going to
be forced to engage in behaviors that
they deem immoral or that they deem
objectively untrue so that's why these
these attempts to pass this law have
failed there were other cases associated
to express filed fired Donald Zarda days
after he mentioned that he's gay
our G&G our Harris Funeral Homes fired
Amy Stevens who is a guy and then one
day Amy Stephens shows up in a dress and
the funeral home says look we we've got
grieving families around here we can't
have this distraction of an obvious man
wearing a dress and so all those cases
went up we're actually going to speak
very very briefly at the end of the show
with the lawyer who argued the Harris
Funeral Homes case so the question is do
protections on the basis of sex protect
sexual preferences and sexual identity
you know a good way to think about this
we talk about title 9 and girls sports
you know or boys allowed to play in
girls sports leagues or not well title
seven is about employment so you've got
a protection of the basis of race you've
got protection of the basis of religion
you got protected a lot of different
protections and you've got protection on
the basis of sex but to sex mean sexual
preference sexual behavior sexual
identity no I mean the simple answer is
no nobody when this law was passed in
1964 thought that that's what it meant
no the the gender ideology that we now
refer to as transgenderism didn't even
really exist in 1964 not certainly not
in the way that we think about it so
certainly not by any any plain reading
of the law this was not protected and
yet
Neil Gorsuch came around and he said it
is protected so what was his argument
his argument is that even though sex you
know male and female biology even though
that is a distinct category from sexual
preferences or sexual identities sure
those are distinct categories but you
can't get a sexual preference without
reference to sex you can't get a sexual
identity without reference to sex
meaning if I am you know the big bad
religious ink and I want to not hire
people who are practicing homosexuals
then I can't fire someone for being a
homosexual without also firing them for
is sex where I can't fire a guy if
you're a man and you're attracted to men
and you're living with a man and you're
doing all sorts of stuff with the man I
can't fire you for doing that unless I
know that you are a man and therefore
I'm discriminated on the basis of sex
this is a pretty weak argument and Sam
Alito who is an actual conservative
explained why this is a weak argument in
his excellent dissent so he points out a
great example in this dissent you don't
have to go read the whole thing though I
I would recommend it a great example is
he says oK you've got a model employee
at your company right and you love this
employee she's doing a great job man she
couldn't be a better employee and then
you the boss show up to the Christmas
party and you meet the employees wife so
you find out that she is a lesbian and
then the next day you go and fire her
because you're a mean bad terrible guy
question is is it legal for you to do
that well in that case as Sam Alito
points out it's pretty clear that you
are not firing her for her sex because
you already knew her sex when she was a
model employee right it's not like she
was hiding that she was a woman from you
you knew she was a woman and you gave
her all sorts of promotions and you
thought she was a great employee you're
merely firing her for engaging in this
homosexual relationship which regardless
of what you think about that whether you
think the employers a mean guy is not
protected by the Civil Rights Act of
1964
most of Alito's dissent though is
actually not even about this question
because look if you think that employers
shouldn't be able to discriminate based
on sexual preferences or sexual identity
or whatever fine go ahead and pass a law
about it that's what we do here in
America that's what our republic is
based on go persuade your fellow
citizens and pass a law but you can't
pass a law because people actually don't
want to change the law so one Road
lawyer in particular Neal bore such a
pretend conservative a traitor came
around and said I'm just gonna rewrite
the law and the the worst part about it
was he did it in the name of originalism
he did it in the name of the pretending
to be reading the text as it would have
been understood when the text was
written so most of Alito's too
was actually about Scalia and the reason
the reason it was actually about the
judicial philosophy and defending Scalia
originalism is because the credibility
of originalism is on the line
originalism interpreting the text to
mean what it meant when it was written
is the Creed of the conservative legal
movement now it's been used to justify
changing the very meaning of sex the
very meaning of sex consider that I mean
I I don't want to sound hyperbolic here
with Neil Gorsuch but the guy was
brought in to replace the most
conservative member of the Supreme Court
he has now not only legislated from the
bench he has fundamentally redefined the
fundamental aspect of our nature which
is sex there is no way now that
conservatives can view Gorsuch as
anything but one of the worst jurists in
the history of the United States not to
put too fine a point on it
what is the conservative judicial
movement gotten us we've gotten a couple
good decisions we got Heller which
protected our Second Amendment rights
Citizens United I guess allows allows
people to donate to political campaigns
and allows businesses to donate to
political campaigns what else we've got
Obamacare still that was a conservative
judge who gave us that we've got a
radical redefinition of marriage from
the bench
we've not overturned Roe vs. Wade we've
upheld it we now have a fictional Civil
Rights Act right of men to wear dresses
at work what has the conservative
judicial movement got us I thought the
judges were so important what what
happened to the judges there is what
there's one positive thing I can say
it's not even really positive but it's
at least helps us understand this
decision which is the way we talk about
the Civil Rights Act the way Neil
Gorsuch talked about the Civil Rights
Act it's very similar to the way that we
talk about the Constitution that might
tell us something we'll get to that in
one second first though I've got to
thank our friends over at NetSuite you
know the last few months have been
little difficult for people who are
running businesses and I think they've
taught a lot of people that being on top
of your numbers is an absolute must
you need NetSuite by Oracle the world's
number one cloud business system finance
HR inventory econ
everything you need all in one place so
you save time money and headaches
whether you're doing a million or
hundreds of millions in sales
NetSuite gives you visibility and
control so you can manage every penny
with precision join over 20,000
companies who trust NetSuite to go
faster with confidence
NetSuite surveyed hundreds of business
leaders and assembled a playbook of the
top strategies they're using as America
reopens for business go get it now I
mean this is actually a great
opportunity especially as we're trying
to all pull ourselves out of this
difficult few months get your free guide
and give it a read seven actions
businesses need to take now schedule
your free product tour at NetSuite calm
slash Knowles get your free guide
schedule your free product tour right
now at NetSuite comm slash Knowles
that's NetSuite comm slash Knowles let's
say that you come down on this question
and you say look sexual preferences
sexual behavior sexual identity surely
are not protected characteristics all
right we I can I should be able to
determine if my employee is a man
wearing a dress let's say you come down
on that side of the equation let's say
you come down on the other side you say
no I think it's outrageous people should
have protections for their sexual
preferences and their behaviors and
their identity men should be allowed to
wear dresses at the office and how dare
you say otherwise let's say you come
down on either side I don't care surely
we can all agree that one robed lawyer
on the Supreme Court should not be the
one deciding that with his gavel for the
whole country my I'm reminded of
Scalia's dissent in obergefell the gay
marriage decision where he said the
question of marriage is not what
primarily interests me what I'm
interested in is who rules me who rules
me am i ruled by the Constitution
am i ruled by some other law or am i
ruled by some traitorous backstabbing
robed lawyer named daniel Gorsuch I hope
it's the Constitution but I don't know
this is the one the one thing I can sort
of say to put a button on this about
Gorsuch his opinion he's writing about
the civil right
Act of 1964 in a in a similar way that
people would write about the
Constitution and I've noticed that we do
this a lot we refer to the protections
in the Civil Rights Act is like they're
almost another kind of Constitution and
this is the thesis of a very popular
book right now I actually just got to
the last chapter this morning and this
book it's very good it's by Chris
Caldwell
it's called age of entitlement America
since the 60s very important to read
because basically the thesis of that
book is that the Civil Rights Act and
the tumult of the 1960s created a new
parallel Constitution and much of our
political rancor is arguing between the
old constitutional order of the late
eighteenth century and the new constant
constitutional order of the 1960s one
defense of Gorsuch sort of that I can
think of is that he's telling us in this
decision that the Civil Rights Act of
1964 was actually much more radical than
any of us want to believe it was because
we all say okay we like the Civil Rights
Act we want to give civil rights to
people we don't want people to be
unfairly discriminated against on the
basis of race that's really what the
Civil Rights Act was about but then was
the was the law written in such a way
that it went far beyond that scope and
it took far more power than any people
thought that they were giving when they
were trying to address this very
specific very specific racial question
in the same way that black lives matter
isn't really about black lives mattering
is it possible the Civil Rights Act
isn't really about civil rights at least
not in the way that we're thinking about
it but it was rather a more radical
leftward lurch of our constitutional
order either way either way huge blow to
trump and it's not Trump's fault
we all thought Gorsuch was fine remember
we were all worried about Cavanaugh we
thought Gorsuch was the rock solid rock
ribbed judge so I don't blame Trump for
this at all but it's a big blow because
Trump is campaigning on the judges right
that was a big part of the 2016 campaign
and now one of his judges ends up being
the worst jurist one of the worst
jurists in American history Trump also
has some more trouble coming down the
pike and I think this is because he's
getting some bad advice from some of his
advisors so you know there have been
these crazy riots there's been the
looting there's been the coronavirus
lockdown
and every time there's one of these
incidents involved with a police
involved killing there's this impulse
for the president to speak out about it
to give an opinion the press Royce
asking questions so there was this
shooting in Atlanta we went through it
yesterday of a drunk driver who was
being arrested for being a drunk driver
he then attacked the police stole their
taser ran away pointed the Taser fired
the Taser and then the police discharged
their weapons and killed him
president Trump was asked about the
scene and his take on it was similar to
his take on other really dark looking
moments you know really dubious moments
of interactions with the police and
civilians he said it's very disturbing I
thought it was a terrible I'm not going
to compare things but I thought it was a
terrible situation I studied it closely
I'm gonna get some reports done today
very strong reports and we'll have a
little more to say about it tomorrow but
certainly it was very to me it was very
disturbing very disturbing it's very
disturbing because shootings are very
disturbing
I agree of course it's very disturbing
you could see the video of this guy
getting shot even if he's a no-good
terrible guy even if he's a criminal
even if he even if even if the killing
was justified it's disturbing to watch a
guy get shot but does anybody think it
wasn't justified the police try to
de-escalate this situation they try not
to use too much force he was able to
wrestle them off him because they
weren't using very much force they steal
his weapon they run away he runs away
they still don't discharge their weapons
the guy then turns aims at them and
fires the Taser gun then they have to
discharge their weapons very sad but but
it's not justified the strongest
argument I've heard actually the only
argument really I've heard as to how the
cops could have gotten out of this
situation without discharging their
weapons is they could have let the drunk
driver now in possession of one of their
weapons just drive away because people
say well they had as a home address they
could have picked him up later so now
you're telling me the best argument
you've got is go let the drunk man get
in a car that'll be safer for everybody
with one of the cops weapons I don't
think so and go home by the way most
people keep their weapons
at home everyone I know who has weapons
keeps most of them at home you're gonna
you're you're seriously saying that no
nobody seriously Simon very sad
situation but clearly justified and
Trump I just don't think he should be
stoking this fire I think he's getting I
think he's getting some bad advice from
people okay and going into this election
you got to be strong especially when
you've got former allies stabbing you in
the back like Neal Gorsuch you've got to
be strong there was a another police
officer who he was not involved in that
killing he himself was shot in the head
he was paralyzed on June 1st you
probably haven't heard very much about
him where are the people coming out
saying that's very disturbing I don't I
don't see very much of that we'll get to
that in one second we'll get to what it
means for law enforcement but first I
got to thank our friends over at honey
you know in the old days back in this
was so long ago I can barely remember
you used to go shopping you'd have to
search for coupons you'd say okay buying
a t-shirt t-shirt coupons you know and
then you've okay at 10% let me use the
code and it doesn't work and you go back
and you took too long come on guys honey
does that for you honey
is PayPal's a new money-saving shopping
tool did you know that with honey you
just go it's in your browser it
automatically applies coupons to your
cart it's a way to save and get free
gift cards to some of your favorite
stores right now our listeners can join
can head to join honey calm slash
Knowles get 500 bonus gold points and
that's only if you use our special URL
I've been using these guys since before
the daily wire existed I've used them
too I mean I'm trying to think the last
time I didn't use honey I use honey for
everything
I just I was just buying some clothing I
saved I think was like 25% I mean I'm
very very good stock I couldn't tell you
I probably saved thousands of dollars
over the years on honey go use it not
using honey is passing up free money add
honey your computer laptop for free at
joy 90 comm slash nulls kena WLA asked
if 500 gold points join honey calm slash
knows this cop che me Colonus was a Las
Vegas police officer who's shot in the
head during a protest that turned
violent there was it a suddenly turned
violent mostly peaceful protest
where they're shooting cops in the head
this happened on June 1st he's paralyzed
from the neck down obviously never gonna
be able to work again he's lucky to be
alive
he's not the only one 700 federal state
and law enforcement local law
enforcement officers have had injuries
during clashes with all those peaceful
rioters according to Justice Department
data 700 where are we going to see that
that's very disturbing imagery where are
we gonna hear about that the left is
pushing an outrageous propaganda battle
right now I mean you see it happening
all the time because they call rioters
and anarchists and communists peaceful
protesters we cannot give in not even
one little inch there is a lot at stake
here folks the conservative judge
quote-unquote just redefined sex from
the bench okay the stakes are very high
here we cannot give an inch to the
leftist narrative what's happening
around the country police are quitting
and they should quit because they've got
no backup whatsoever from any of the
elected politicians and they could have
their lives ruined for just for doing
their job down in Florida in Hallandale
Beach Florida the entire SWAT team just
resigned they're gonna remain on the
force but they just resigned they
resigned because their Department and
their elected officials aren't going to
back them up they sent a memo of
grievances to chief Sonia Quino NACE of
the Hallandale Beach Police saying that
look no hard feelings but you're not
going to back us up we can't risk our
lives like this and our livelihoods and
our reputations they're totally right
now luckily there is some good news on
the other side some people at least are
going after some of the rioters and the
criminals the DOJ has charged 50 of the
peaceful rioters with crimes a lot of
these crimes include arson it includes
aiming a laser at a police aircraft it
includes tossing Molotov cocktails into
law enforcement vehicles and the windows
of stores it includes toppling
historically significant statues on
federal land right
they've now charged 50 people looking
around at those riots looks like there
were more than 50 people doing bad
things so good 50 down that's a good
thing
fifty thousand to go that's the
situation that we're in right now it's
only going to get more intense through
the election and maybe even after the
election you know they always say don't
worry about what's happening on campuses
because what's happening on campuses
it's just these silly snowflakes when
they get to the real world things will
change I don't think so I think actually
the real world is acquiescing to the
crazy snowflakes and we had another
incident on campus there's a guy at
Oklahoma State his name is Csaba Hubbard
he's a football player I take it I don't
know anything about Oklahoma State
football I don't know anything about
Java Hubbard but Java Hubbard was very
upset because the coach for the team was
photographed wearing an OE n t-shirt you
know oh and I go ah no way and all the
time
Oh Ann is a conservative news channel
president Trumbull of Zoe any tweets
about how much he likes it at Liz
wheelers is one of the hosts on oen you
know we've had Liz wheeler on this show
so he's wearing the t-shirt of a
conservative news channel and this
player this 21 year old punk chubba
Hubbard tweets out quote I will not
stand for this this is completely
insensitive to everything going on in
society and it's unacceptable
I will not be doing anything with
Oklahoma State until things change good
I hope you don't I hope he doesn't do
anything I hope his resignation from the
team is not only accepted but requested
because his behavior is outrageous and
we're now at a point in this country
where 21 year old Punk's can demand that
their coaches get fired for wearing
t-shirts that say what I like a
conservative news channel that could
happen to any of us any person who
mentions though you know I I watched Fox
News the other day oh I watched Oh a n
the other day oh I watched the daily
wire the other day right Oh Kevin to any
of us of course
not really what happened though they
refused to take a hard line on this I
thought they were gonna fire the coach
they didn't do that by the way they got
the kid I don't even he's American
he's a Canadian he might also be
American but I threw up in Alberta
Canada she's now got this Canadian guy
coming down and trying to get Americans
fired for liking conservative TV
channels you got a kind of forced
apology from the coach yesterday this
part was really humiliating players feel
like it can make our organization or
concert even better than is here
Oklahoma State and I'm looking forward
to making some changes and it starts at
the top with me and we got good days
mm-hmm
excuse me sorry I just had to try to
keep my morning coffee down watching
that pathetic pathetic example now at
least the coach didn't apologize for
wearing the t-shirt of a conservative
news channel I guess then we'd all have
to apologize any of you anybody watching
on The Daily wire or listening on The
Daily wire or reading the de la wire
would have to apologize like they did
something wrong but so fortunately he
didn't go quite that far but he said
he's gonna change and he realizes it
sends him whats sensitive we're the
t-shirt there's nothing sensitive about
wearing that t-shirt you don't need to
change anything about wearing that
t-shirt what needs to change is this
presumptuous Punk trying to get you
fired for having a political view that
he disagrees with now that presumptuous
Punk for his end did also sort of
apologize in the second part of this
video which was much better in the first
part of this video
[Music]
tweet something that really changed
actually went to it as a man and I'm all
about action so that was bad on my part
but from now on we're gonna focus on
bringing change and that's the most
important thing okay until the last like
three words I actually really liked this
he's right he shouldn't have sent that
tweet if he had a problem with the coach
he should have gone to the coach like a
man it's bad that's on him okay I
actually I give the kid credit for
saying all those things not sure he
wanted to say those things clearly
someone was filming it but at least he
did it he gets credit for that but then
at the end goes we're gonna make change
what shape what change that's the most
important thing no the most important
thing is for you to play football and
maybe go to class a few times and get
your degree you're a student athlete do
that be a student learn things throw the
ball
then when you graduate if you want to
run for the Senate go run for the Senate
that's fine these days you frankly that
Kittel probably it's probably better
than half the Senators which is really
unfortunate but college football college
sports is not the place to do that not
every aspect of society needs to be
hopelessly politicized and ginned up to
level 11 not everything you do not
wearing a stupid t-shirt of a TV channel
you like needs to be a major political
statement where you could lose your job
for it okay the way they've left this is
basically at a truce they should have
left it if we wanted to actually have a
decent effect on the culture where the
coach was totally right and the kid was
booted from the team but that's probably
not gonna happen because we're living in
a radical place so radical that Chaz the
autonomous zone of Seattle is now
changing its name to chop which really
gives me a lot of french revolution
vibes I don't know about you we'll get
to that in one second we'll get to more
radical proposals but first I got to
thank you for one making my Michael Nolt
show YouTube channel shoot way past
Clavin because a lot of people watch
this on the daily wire YouTube channel
fine whatever that's great give Bend the
views but you got to go subscribe to the
Michael null show you tube channel so
thank you for doing that
by the way speaking of my friend Andrew
Clavin and
my friend Ben Shapiro we're gonna have a
backstage on Thursday so come check that
out and then you know go back to that
Michael no show YouTube channel and you
will get bonus interviews segments
breakouts a two brand new interviews one
with my friend Maddy Kern's
and we've you know we've posted some
interviews with her before and with John
birch
I'll play a little bit at the end of
this show but we will have the full
interview with the lawyer who argued the
case of this huge Supreme Court case
that came out yesterday we will have him
on my youtube channel by the way you
know you're getting lies from the
mainstream media so get a daily wire
readers pass it's usually three bucks a
month I'm gonna for you just for you my
friend my friend
take that price down two thirds so it'll
be 99 cents for your first month you get
a lot of in-depth analysis that you are
it's certainly not gonna get from the
mainstream media head to Daly wire.com
slash subscribe we'll be right back with
a lot more
Chazz the autonomous Principality of
Chazz which is that six block anarchist
zone in Seattle stands for the Capitol
Hill autonomous zone has changed its
name to chop which is a little more
honest to me when they start bringing in
the guillotines chop stands for Capitol
Hill organized protests why did they
change the name I kid you not
they changed the name so that they could
keep getting welfare checks people
people familiar with the situation have
said this was a big reason why they
changed the name because if you're an
autonomous state an autonomous country
then you're not allowed to get welfare
checks from other countries I guess you
could get foreign aid which is sort of a
welfare check from our country and we
give it though
way too many people but probably Chazz
wasn't going to get too much foreign aid
so they changed it to chop so they can
keep getting their welfare checks and
their food stamps and all the government
goodies from the United States all the
while protesting the United States they
also were a little worried that by
declaring themselves an autonomous
country it would give the federal
government more of an opportunity to
crack down on them whereas if they're
just saying it's a protest then the
government won't crack down government
should crack down this has gone on too
long okay and conservatives always play
it slow they play it soft I'll give you
an example in the courts the Left says
we're gonna we're going to put up
leftist judges who are going to give us
leftist outcomes and we're gonna ask
them case by case how they would rule
and we're gonna get good leftists
leftists never put up a judge and then
accidentally get a conservative
conservatives often put up judges and
accidentally get leftists and liberals
because we do it all we go so backwards
we say okay we're gonna put up judges
who they're not conservative but they're
going to give us an outcome that is you
know it's based on this other judicial
philosophy and we might not always like
the outcomes but it'll it'll be good and
we actually can't ask them about any
cases and how they would rule
but hopefully they'll be okay and as so
anyway let's hope everything works out
for the best and then you get David
Souter a turncoat Republican appointed
judge who became a liberal you get
Sandra Day O'Connor dinner you get John
dinner and dinner ditto
you get John Roberts ditto you get
Kennedy ditto
you get Neil Gorsuch did oka happens
time and time again we we don't use
force we get this radical movement like
BLM which is openly founded by Marxists
BLM which is based on a lie the lie of
Ferguson that that Michael Brown was
executed in Ferguson with his hands up
saying don't shoot completely
contradicted by grand jury by
eyewitnesses my black eye witnesses by
the multiple autopsies by everything
still based on this lie and some
conservatives say well we should try to
come to an understanding with it no
there's no understanding you're buying
into the lie that BLM is about black
lives mattering it's not you're buying
into the lie that these are peaceful
protesters they're not they're rioters
who created their own autonomous country
you're buying into the lie that it's an
organized protest go in there with force
and stop them from occupying streets
there we're now getting word that
they're they're running an extortion
racket on businesses in the area that's
not fair we know that they're they're
using unjust force on other people we
know that they're that these riders have
been attacking people burning down
buildings murdering people stop it stop
allowing this to happen
use force no middle ground stand in the
middle of the road you're gonna get hit
by a truck a lot more radicalism coming
down the pike on other policies as well
here's one proposal this one this might
be the stupidest proposal I've seen in
weeks
in in weeks of many stupid proposals
which is to reduce the workweek
to four days because Americans right now
you know they're just too overworked
well we have thousands and thousands of
people pouring out into the streets just
burning stuff because they've got
nothing else to do well you've got
millions and millions of people who were
thrown out of their jobs some people on
left some geniuses like Andrew yang
think that the bigger problem in America
is that we are overworked here's mr.
Yang's proposal for a four-day workweek
right now
our workweek is getting longer not
shorter and it's having a disastrous set
of effects on millions of people where
we have this mental health crisis that
we talked about last week we have this
worship of work work ISM and we're
sleep-deprived I mean you can name it
they're like all these stacked effects
and it's getting worse now economists
like Keynes projected we'd have a 15
hour work week by now because we'd be so
wealthy and it turns out he was right
about the level of wealth like it like
that line was correct but he obviously
got the number of hours in the work week
very wrong because it's been getting
longer not shorter here in the US and
Barack Obama actually said to me we
should be looking at a shorter work week
because firms aren't going to employ
people in the same way that they have
previously so here's my tip off that
this is a bad idea is that Barack Obama
is wrong about everything and then my
next tip off of this a bad idea is that
John Maynard Keynes the economist is
wrong about everything and then my third
tip off that this is a bad idea is that
Andrew yang is wrong about everything
what they get wrong is they think it's
bad for man to work they think work is
this awful punishment and if we could
cure work if we could fix having to work
that would be so much better for human
flourishing and they're wrong we were
made to work we're made to where the
earliest chapters of Genesis we work by
the sweat of our brow we shall earn our
keep even before Adam was kicked out of
the garden he is working he's gardening
you know he's naming things we have to
do things when you don't do things you
become a couch potato and you get
depressed and you get a little
radicalized maybe and you go out into
the street and burn things if anything
we need a longer workweek okay but I
think we can settle on the compromise of
keeping the current workweek we have in
getting people
back to work because a lot of the civil
unrest as it is called a lot of the
riots and the burning in the arson I
think is because we've told people that
they can't work now for three months
idle hands are the devil's playground
and it's no surprise to me that Barack
Obama would be encouraging that kind of
thing a lot of other left-wing groups
pushing this idea NBC was was pushing
this idea that the four-day workweek is
what we need it's not I think part of
the reason they're pushing it in some
ways is so that they can keep the
economy depressed until the election but
part of it is because they misunderstand
human nature and we can't permit that
all right we have we got Chazz now chop
we got chop not because people are
overworked but because they are under
worked ok I don't think those guys
running chopped right now or slaving
away at the coal mines too often we got
this stuff we got these riots because we
are indulging vagrants and radicals some
people need a stern talking-to ok a lot
of people need a stern talking-to like
the people in chop like that student
athlete like neal Gorsuch and the
conservative judicial movement we need
to get a little tougher folks ok they
the answer right now is not to go weak
at the knees there was a woman in chop
actually who showed this perfectly this
woman I want her to run for Senate I
don't know who she is I don't know what
her name is
I love her she's inside the chop
neighborhood she is a black woman she's
talking to a white liberal woman and
this white liberal woman presumably
before their cameras turned on was
espousing her stupid radical ideas and
then this young black woman was just
slowly explaining to this white liberal
woman why everything she thought is
wrong
let me tell you something
history has there was there was be still
my beating heart
oh my gosh when she gets to the sexual
revolution and feminism be still my
beating heart she makes a really great
point here I mean I encourage you to
watch there a number of videos of her we
don't have time to play the whole thing
she makes this really great point which
is white liberals and white leftist
radicals are foisting a lot of
radicalism on the black community so
cold that really historically has no
place there to think about the LGBT
movement getting back to our Supreme
Court decision earlier in the show don't
forget the way that we got gay marriage
meaning the radical redefinition of
marriage from what it had never meant to
now this new thing we didn't get it
through voting why didn't we get a
through voting they tried to do it
through voting remember they did prop 8
in California and part of the reason
that the redefinition of marriage was
defeated on that ballot initiative is
because black voters overwhelmingly
turned out against it for many many
years black voters did not support
redefining marriage
they did not support the kind of radical
sexual revolutionary leftism that you
saw mostly from white activists same
thing with feminism 11 she goes yeah
listen white liberal ladies your whole
thing of like feminism is great and you
know I'm gonna do what I want and we're
not gonna have any sort of respectful
relations between the sexes
we don't do that that's not that's not
what we do and our point is well-taken I
don't know if it's well taken by the
white liberal lady but it is well taken
by everyone else this point she makes on
abortion it is true but black women are
disproportionately likely to have
abortions now but that is by design
they're the the abortion movement that
began in the early 20th century in
earnest specifically targeted black
communities there is a reason why
Planned Parenthood disproportionately
sets up shop in black communities there
has been a plan okay and I what this
woman is recognizing she says this is
bad we should not wait I don't we don't
want to be killing our children this is
a bad idea this has been bad for our
community a little tough talk goes a
long way Trump made this point in the
80s he took out a whole ad in the New
York Times I think it was in The Times
or the post or maybe both where he said
he was actually criticizing Reagan's
foreign policy he said you got to get
tough a little bit of toughness goes a
long way okay it'll solves a lot of
problems now is not the time for
conservatives at the federal state or
local at the legislative executive or
judicial level to go soft we are at a
fever pitch right now and it's going to
get even tougher through November do not
go soft buckle down this is the fight
and every time we lose one of these
episodes we cede that ground very likely
forever at least for the foreseeable
future that's why this ruling from the
Supreme Court was so devastating we sat
down for quite a while with my friend
john bersia was the lead lawyer on the
harris funeral-home case we sat down
with him yesterday here's just a quick
clip of that you can see the rest of it
in my youtube channel the point I guess
of that case is that there's a con
flicked between traditional sexual
protections and gender ideology meaning
if you've got protections on the basis
of sex then that could be interpreted to
protect women from say men interfering
in their institutions but if you
interpret sex to mean sexual identity
then that completely undermines the
purpose of those sex protections because
all of a sudden then men are allowed to
interfere in those institutions and
actually they're totally entitled to by
that interpretation now I know this is a
separate case we're not talking about
girls sports here we're talking about
employment but what what is the effect
of this going to be I mean it seems like
we can't have two standards running
against one another forever no you can't
and you can bet that activists are going
to take this ruling and try to apply it
in the title nine context and in other
cases for those of your listeners who
aren't familiar with some of that
litigation there's a number of cases
pending but the first one the one that's
farthest long in the federal court
system is in Connecticut where three
women sued because two men identifying
as women have 115 state track and field
titles and the girls division over the
last two seasons Oh shocker they're that
way boys are men against girls they
typically win and when they went to
title nine officials they were told that
girls have the right to participate but
not the right to win now no one who
enacted title nine as kind of the
penultimate law to ensure equal
opportunity for women and girls in
sports would have ever thought that's
what title nine men and yet the Court's
ruling today that's exactly where we are
so now this question of sex is all of a
sudden in question which no one would
have imagined when these statutes were
passed and what's so tragic about this
is that in real life you don't see very
many cases at all of businesses or
schools or anybody else using their
ideas about marriage and sex to punish
people it's always the other way around
you activists make these laws they
weaponize them and then they use them to
punish anybody who has a different view
and we should all be able to agree that
biology is not bigotry and believing
that a man based on physiology biology
can't change is not discrimination and
similarly that marriage between man and
one
is not discrimination in all other areas
our culture purportedly embraces
diversity but in these areas people are
continually trying to shut down those
views and this Court decision is only
going to add to that conflict biology is
not bigotry that is a very good line
because one thing I've noticed today is
you see a lot of left wingers and
frankly even some people who would call
themselves on the right saying oh who
cares about this what you know I'm sorry
for you that now you can't discriminate
against homosexuals and transgender
people but get with the program it's
2020
stop being so hateful stop being so
bigoted what are we supposed to say to
accusations like that well then they'd
love to pull out the hateful and bigoted
things because that gets people to their
opinion and it also forces others who
are worried about public recombinations
to just be silent when they really
shouldn't be well despite what the
Supreme Court said today it said an
obergefell that people who hold the
belief that marriage is between one man
and one woman is honorable and has been
logical and based on sound principles
for thousands of years like why someone
who believes that sex is immutable and
based on physiology you know that that's
a common-sense science-based
proposition and don't even get me in to
the left and how they embrace science
well rejecting science at every step of
the way convenient convenient yeah so
what we need to do is do a much better
job explaining to the rest of society
the rest of culture why we hold those
beliefs why men who are more and men
remain men the same for women why
marriage is between one man and one
woman and when we can communicate the
logic behind those ideas people will
hopefully start to understand that we
come from those positions I would have
sound reasonable thinking out of natural
law principles out of science and
biology and ultimately what's wanting
what's best for every human individual
that if you hold those beliefs it's all
about protecting human dignity not about
rejecting it and so we have to just
dismiss those who malign those views as
being hateful and bigoted because it's
their views and their attempt to shut
down everybody from talking about this
in the public square that is the the
real hatred biology is not bigotry
except now according to the Supreme
Court
according to
the conservative judge who replaced in
Antonin Scalia it is big setback very
tough time for conservatives and with
judges like that you have to wonder what
are we conserving and how much longer
will there be anything to conserve lots
of important questions as we head into
November and as we head into tomorrow
we'll have a lot more in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
borne supervising producers Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling technical
producer
Austin Stephens assistant director Pavel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
fenders hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there